[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Weihnachtsdessert.
Und zwar habe ich mir gedacht
– ich habe ja im Sommer schon mal
eine Bolo-Tsunami-Torte gemacht,
also eine Torte, die in so einer Tortenrandfolie steckt,
und wenn man die Tortenrandfolie dann hochnimmt,
dann läuft die Schokocreme
über den Kuchen wie ein Tsunami.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
das Ganze mache ich jetzt für Weihnachten
vielleicht so als Mini-Cake,
also als Minitörtchen.
Und dann hat jeder Gast oder jeder am Tisch,
jedes Familienmitglied einfach so eine kleine Torte.
Und dann ist es voll die Überraschung,
wenn man dann eben die Folie wegzieht.
Und man hat ein schönes Weihnachtsdessert.
Ich kann nur nicht versprechen,
dass das Ergebnis so gut wird, wie ich es mir vorstelle.
Aber wir machen das jetzt einfach.
Vielleicht wird es ein Schmecksperiment.
Ist dann auch egal.
Am Ende machen wir Rumkugeln draus.
Okay, ich mache jetzt erst mal einen Biskuit.
Denn wir haben zwei, drei,
vier, fünf Bestandteile, die jetzt zubereitet werden müssen.
Für den Biskuit nehme ich
drei Eier,
– die sind zimmerwarm –
eine Prise Salz,
75 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
50 Gramm Mehl,
25 Gramm Kakao.
Und hier habe ich noch Spekulatiuskekse.
Jetzt könnt ihr entweder eine Küchenmaschine nehmen
oder eben ein Handrührgerät.
Ich nehme jetzt die Eier,
Zucker und Salz.
Vanilleextrakt kommt dazu.
Und dann wird die Masse richtig schaumig aufgeschlagen.
Also es darf ruhig zehn, fünfzehn Minuten lang gerührt werden.
Und in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr auch schon mal
den Backofen vorheizen auf 190°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
[Musik]
So. Die restlichen Zutaten werde ich jetzt dazu sieben,
also Mehl
und Kakao.
So befreit ihr das Mehl und den Kakao eben von Klümpchen.
Und dann müsst ihr wirklich nur noch ganz, ganz kurz rühren,
also gerade so ein bisschen unterheben.
>> JOSH: Nicht auf den Rand schlagen, oder?
>> SALLY: Da darfst du den Schneebesen
nicht auf den Rand schlagen. Ganz genau, Josh.
Denn wir haben jetzt so viel Luft eingearbeitet.
Guck mal, wie luftig das ist!
Wenn du das jetzt schlägst, dann tschüss.
Tschüss, Luft.
>> SARAH: Wenn Kai Pflaume das jetzt hören würde.
>> SALLY: Der Kai würde jetzt hier...
>> SARAH: Tschüss, frische Luft.
>> SALLY: Tschüss, frische Luft.
Ich glaube, ich nehme aber tatsächlich
doch weniger Spekulatius.
Den brösle ich noch rein,
so als kleiner Crunch.
Das ist jetzt wieder so ein Rezept, wo ich mir so denke:
"Hättest du es doch vorher ausprobiert."
Und dann denke ich mir so:
"Ach nee, das macht so viel mehr Spaß."
So bleibt die Spannung erhalten.
Wäre ja langweilig.
Und jetzt könnt ihr den Biskuit entweder
auf
einfach einem Backblech backen
oder in einem Backrahmen
und das Ganze später ausstechen
oder ihr nehmt jetzt direkt Miniförmchen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach diese Burger- und Törtchenringe
und werde jetzt da den Teig einfüllen.
Dann habe ich nämlich direkt schon die perfekte Größe.
Aber, wie gesagt, ihr könnt es auch als Platte backen
und später dann eben dementsprechend mit einem Glas
oder mit einem Ausstecher einfach ausstechen.
Das geht auch.
Jetzt gucke ich mal, für wie viele die Masse reicht.
Vielleicht war es auch zu wenig Masse.
[Musik]
Jetzt so ein bisschen glatt streichen.
Und dann können die Törtchen schon gebacken werden.
Und ich werde die Backzeit nutzen
und schon mal eine Fruchteinlage machen.
[Musik]
Also mache ich jetzt mal die Fruchteinlage.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt Himbeeren und Blaubeeren
– die waren jetzt aus dem TK –
und nehme Agar Agar dazu, also ein pflanzliches Geliermittel.
Und die Früchte könnt ihr auch gern schon auftauen lassen.
Ich werde sie jetzt einfach direkt im Topf pürieren.
Und Fruchteinlagen liebe ich einfach,
weil sie eben eingekocht werden.
Das Agar Agar bindet das Ganze ja auch.
Ich süße es auch wirklich gar nicht.
Und dann habt ihr einfach eine schöne fruchtige Note.
Und die passen wirklich zu allen Torten,
also sowohl zu Schokotorten als auch zu Vanilletorten,
fruchtig, nussig.
Und vor allem kann man die super vorbereiten.
Denn die werden danach eingefroren
und dann habt ihr die einfach auf Vorrat
und könnt sie dann für die Torten benutzen.
Und die Früchte werden eben nicht schlecht
dadurch, dass sie eingekocht werden,
und schmecken eben auch nach zwei, drei Tagen noch gut,
also in der Torte.
Und es wird halt nicht matschig.
Das ist das Schöne.
Also jetzt kurz pürieren.
[Musik]
Ich gebe jetzt noch für den Geschmack
ein bisschen Tonka Wonka dazu.
Ihr könnt auch einfach eine Tonkabohne dazu reiben,
also eine Prise, nicht die ganze.
Denn Tonkabohne ist so wie Zimt oder auch Muskatnuss
einfach giftig, wenn es zu viel ist.
Aber so klein dosiert, ist es megalecker.
Und ich finde, es hat auch
– also es passt zu allen Geschmacksrichtungen.
Es schmeckt für mich so ein bisschen wie Waldmeister,
aber auch nach Mandel und Marzipan.
Manche finden, es schmeckt nach Vanille.
Und deswegen, finde ich, passt es auch perfekt
jetzt in so ein Weihnachtsrezept
und vor allem in so gemischte Früchte.
Perfekt!
Mit Wasser ist das Ganze jetzt auch ein bisschen verdünnter,
kann jetzt schön aufkochen.
Und Agar Agar hat einfach den Vorteil, dass es pflanzlich ist.
Ich muss es einfach zwei Minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen lassen.
Aber das ist okay.
Die Zeit warte ich jetzt kurz
und räume in der Zwischenzeit auf.
[Musik]
Also ich habe jetzt das Ganze gekocht.
Ich mache jetzt keine Gelierprobe.
Wenn ihr euch aber nicht seid,
ob das Agar Agar wirkt,
dann macht ruhig eine Gelierprobe.
Also einfach so einen kleinen Teelöffel voll
in ein kleines Schälchen geben, kurz kühl stellen
und dann seht ihr, ob es fest wird.
Falls es nicht fest wird,
einfach kurz noch mal aufkochen.
Und ich fülle das jetzt hier kurz in einen Messbecher.
Denn dann kann ich
das Ganze hier reinfüllen.
Also die Fruchteinlagen brauchen jetzt
einfach eine kleine Form.
Ich mache das jetzt hier in Silikonförmchen.
Ihr könnt auch aber Pralinenförmchen nehmen.
Oder, wenn ihr es ein bisschen weiter abkühlen lasst,
könnt ihr auch so Verpackungsmaterial nehmen
wie zum Beispiel von Toffifee.
Die haben ja auch so kleine Rundungen.
Die sind zwar kleiner,
aber, wie gesagt, ihr könnt jede beliebige Form nehmen.
Und jetzt hier ein bisschen reinfüllen,
nicht randvoll, sondern wirklich nur mini.
[Musik]
Dann jetzt hier kurz fest werden lassen auf Raumtemperatur
und dann einfach direkt in den Gefrierschrank geben,
damit die Fruchteinlage schön fest wird.
Und während die fest wird,
kann ich schon den dritten Bestandteil machen
und das ist der Bolo Tsunami,
also die Schokosoße.
Für den Bolo Tsunami verwende ich
150 Gramm Schlagsahne,
190 Gramm Milch,
12 Gramm Stärke,
150 Gramm weiße Schokolade
– 150 Gramm weiße Schokolade,
190 Gramm gezuckerte Kondensmilch,
150 Gramm saure Sahne,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und vielleicht noch mal 75 Gramm Sahne.
Okay. Die Bolo-Tsunami-Glasur
hatte ich beim letzten Mal dunkel gemacht,
also mit Zartbitterschokolade,
dieses Mal mit weißer Schokolade.
Daher muss ich auch die Sahnemenge am Ende
– ich muss mal gucken, ob ich die noch brauche oder nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Jetzt gebe ich erst mal
die erste Portion Sahne,
die Milch
und die Stärke in den Topf.
Das Ganze wird jetzt schön verrührt,
darf dann auch aufkochen
wie so eine Art flüssiger Pudding.
Oh, das war doch der Tag,
an dem wir so viel Pudding gemacht haben.
>> JOSH: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Es war so alles mit Pudding.
Buttercreme mit Pudding, alles mit Pudding.
Es war wirklich so.
Ich habe aus Versehen
– ich wollte ja beim letzten Bolo Tsunami
zwei Torten machen,
halt eine so backstage, so nebenher.
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Ja, komm,
dann mache ich halt noch mal die Menge"
und habe die dann noch angepasst.
Und ich wollte irgendwie die 1,5-fache Menge machen
und habe aus Versehen die dreifache Menge gemacht.
Weißt du das noch?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: So statt der halben Menge dazu,
einfach noch mal die dreifache Portion.
Ja, wir hatten echt eine Woche lang
– und jeder hat noch mit heim genommen –
Bolo-Tsunami-Soße.
Aber die war richtig lecker.
>> JOSH: Die war Hammer!
>> SALLY: Die war der Hammer.
So.
Da kommt wieder der Schwabe in mir durch.
Also das Ganze schön aufkochen.
[Musik]
Jetzt merke ich schon, dass die Masse eindickt
durch die Stärke.
Aber ich muss sie jetzt wirklich einmal schön kochen lassen.
Und wenn die Soße kocht, könnt ihr den Herd ausschalten,
die weiße Schokolade einrühren.
Mh! Ist da eine Fliege geflogen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die wäre fast drin gelandet.
[Musik]
Und wenn sich die Schokolade aufgelöst hat,
einfach die restlichen Zutaten dazu geben,
also hier einmal die gezuckerte Kondensmilch.
Die hat ja schon so eine dicke Konsistenz.
Die saure Sahne,
die ist auch für den Geschmack, muss ich sagen, da.
Es schmeckt dann nicht so schwer.
Das ist schon so eine kleine Kalorienbombe.
Aber komm,
passt.
Und Vanilleextrakt.
Und dann lasse ich das Ganze erst mal abkühlen abgedeckt
und gucke später, ob ich die Sahne noch brauche.
Aber ich glaube es fast nicht.
Denn
ich denke, das ist schon flüssig genug.
Weil die dunkle Schokolade wird ja fester als die weiße
und bei der habe ich dann noch mal Sahne gebraucht,
aber ich glaube, bei der nicht.
Also lassen wir das schön abkühlen.
Und inzwischen ist auch schon der Biskuit fertig,
die Fruchteinlage vielleicht schon gefroren.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt schon mal die Tortencreme machen
– die Törtchencreme.
Es sind ja Törtchen.
Es ist so.
[Musik]
Für die Schokoladencreme nehme ich
100 Gramm Vollmilchschokolade,
250 Gramm Mascarpone,
250 Gramm Quark
und 250 Gramm Sahne,
einen Teelöffel Spekulatiusgewürz
und zum Festigen noch ein bisschen San-apart
oder Sahnesteif.
Schokoladencreme.
Ich nehme jetzt erst mal die Vollmilchschokolade.
Die kann hier geschmolzen werden.
Sarah, gönne dir einfach deine Spätzle.
Achje!
Hauptsache, so Spätzle im Hintergrund gegessen.
Läuft bei uns.
So. Hier einfach über dem warmen Wasserbad.
Ich habe das Wasser vorhin kurz kochen lassen,
den Herd ausgemacht.
Das kann jetzt hier schmelzen.
Und da muss ich drauf warten.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich hier schon mal
die Törtchen rauslösen.
[Musik]
Und ich drücke dabei, muss ich sagen
– das habe ich bei Sarah gelernt.
Denn sie hat neulich den perfekten Biskuit
einfach so unperfekt rausgelöst.
Darf ich das sagen?
Komm, ich darf das sagen, oder?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil du bist so eine perfekte Frau,
nur den Biskuit hast du nicht so perfekt rausgelöst.
>> SARAH: Backen kann ich.
Oh, das hast du jetzt aber schön gesagt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich meine, es muss ja auch was geben, was man nicht kann.
Ich kann nicht singen
und Sarah konnte bisher keinen Biskuit rauslösen.
Jetzt lernt sie es.
Guckt mal.
>> SARAH: Jetzt lernst du singen.
>> SALLY: Oh! Der hat sich von alleine rausgelöst.
Ich lerne vielleicht noch singen.
Ich glaube aber nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Talent, was mir nicht gegeben ist.
Aber egal.
Gut, der hat sich jetzt von alleine rausgelöst, aber
ihr müsst es halt im Prinzip so machen:
Das Tortenringmesser hier ansetzen
und wirklich so gegen den Rand drücken,
also eher am Rand entlang als am Biskuit entlang,
damit wirklich
der Biskuit schön rausgelöst werden kann.
So.
Und die wasche ich jetzt noch kurz aus
und bereite sie auch schon mal vor.
Denn die brauche ich gleich noch mal.
Die Schokolade ist jetzt geschmolzen.
Ich bin ja eigentlich nicht so der Vollmilchschokoladenfan,
aber ich glaube, da drin schmeckt es ganz gut.
Vor allem muss ich da jetzt keinen Zucker mehr dazu geben,
weil Vollmilchschokolade einfach schon süß genug schmeckt.
Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt hier Zartbitter nimmt,
dann schmeckt es echt zu herb.
Und ich denke, gerade so als Weihnachtsdessert
ist es eine gute Süße.
Außerdem habt ihr mit Sicherheit
noch ganz viele Schokonikoläuse übrig
und die könnt ihr jetzt zu Weihnachten resteverwerten.
Denn davon hat man ja echt immer zu viele.
Gute Resteverwertungscreme.
So. Jetzt hier Mascarpone und Schokolade verrühren
ganz kurz.
Sehr gut.
Denn die Schokolade war jetzt nicht heiß.
Deswegen ist das okay.
Die kann man direkt warm dazu geben.
Die Mascarpone, die kühlt die dann gut runter.
[Musik]
Und mit San-apart steif schlagen.
Okidoki, filli, filli.
>> JOSH: Crazy, crazy!
>> SALLY: Schneidi, schneidi.
Jetzt werden die Törtchen nämlich gefüllt.
Und damit die alle später auch alle gleich aussehen,
möchte ich die Törtchen
– weil ich ja vorhin
die Menge nicht abgemessen habe vom Biskuit,
will ich sie einmal kurz gleichmäßig schneiden
mit einer Tortensäge.
Ihr könnt auch ein Messer nehmen.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch so lassen, wenn ihr sagt, ist egal.
Aber ich will jetzt, dass überall die Optik natürlich gleich ist.
Deswegen hier einmal den Deckel weg.
Wenn ihr jetzt den Tortenring befüllen wollt,
könnt ihr das natürlich auch ohne Tortenrandfolie machen.
Aber der Bolo Tsunami, der lebt natürlich davon,
dass man diese Folie drumherum hat.
Denn später bekommt ja jeder ein Törtchen auf den Tisch
und darf dann die Folie hochnehmen
und dann läuft eben der Bolo Tsunami drüber.
Deswegen hier einfach so eine Tortenrandfolie rein.
Ich habe jetzt die mit 10 cm Höhe.
Denn die 5 cm ist mir
für das jetzt hier zu flach.
Was ihr bedenken müsst, dass ihr später
das Ganze mit einem Klebeband fixiert,
damit das, wenn ich den Ring entferne, eben nicht aufgeht.
Das wäre ziemlich blöd,
wenn das aufgeht, bevor man das fertig hat.
Also hier einfach so ein bisschen abmessen
und ein bisschen Überschuss einberechnen.
Und die Folie, die könnt ihr auch immer wiederverwenden,
also ihr müsst die wirklich nicht wegschmeißen.
Ihr habt ja auch gesehen, die eine habe ich ja halbiert.
Die hatte ich nämlich neulich bei einer großen Torte.
Und auch bei den kleinen
kann ich die einfach schön auswaschen
und dann eben wieder benutzen.
Das ist nämlich eine schöne feste Folie auch.
[Musik]
Buraya.
Hm, iksinede.
Hm.
Er hat gerade gefragt, ob er die Kids hierher bringen soll.
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Ja, beide."
Ja, ihr könnt auch Abstandhölzer nehmen.
Ich muss echt sagen,
meine Tortensäge ist irgendwie abhandengekommen.
Aber, wie gesagt, so geht es auch.
Also ihr müsst einfach zwei Gegenstände nehmen,
die gleich hoch sind.
Das können jetzt entweder die Teighölzer sein
oder zum Beispiel
Bauklötzchen.
Bauklötzchen gehen auch.
>> JOSH: Bauklötzchen in der Küche?
>> SALLY: Bauklötzchen hatte ich ja auch schon.
>> JOSH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Bei Fondanttorten, klar.
Alles, was der Haushalt hergibt.
Ah, weißt du, warum der sich schlecht schneiden lässt?
Wegen den Spekulatiusstücken.
>> JOSH: Ah!
>> SALLY: Deswegen ist der so ein bisschen widerspenstig.
[Musik]
Dann lege ich jetzt hier immer einen Boden rein.
Hast du das gesehen? Wie so ein Fahrstuhl!
Der ist einfach runtergerutscht.
Achtung.
Tschu!
Okay.
Das war unelegant.
>> JOSH: Hm.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt könnt ihr die Füllung
einfach hier in einen Spritzbeutel füllen.
Ich habe hier vorne eine Lochtülle schon dran.
Ihr könnt es natürlich auch mit einem Löffel einfüllen,
aber mit dem Spritzbeutel könnt ihr jetzt
ein bisschen sauberer arbeiten.
Das ist so der große Vorteil.
Und jetzt hier so eine kleine Menge schon mal reingeben.
Guckst du mal?
Und das geht echt sauber.
So eine ganz dünne Schicht.
Dann kommt da jetzt die Fruchteinlage rein,
die mir aus der Hand rutscht.
Guckt. So sieht die jetzt aus, richtig süß,
schön flach, aber eine tolle Rundung.
Die kommt jetzt hier mittenrein.
Oh!
Ist schon schön.
So leicht reindrücken.
[Musik]
Ich brösle jetzt einfach noch einen Spekulatius mit rein.
Denn, was ich bei meinem anderen Bolo Tsunami hatte,
war natürlich
– es war ja Erdbeerzeit.
Und ich habe Erdbeeren aufgeschnitten...
>> MURAT: Ich erzähle das...
>> SALLY: Er übertönt mich sogar ohne Mikrofon.
Ich muss Weihnachten retten!
Ich muss Weihnachtstörtchen machen.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich mache gerade mit dem Papa zusammen,
mit dem Güni zusammen eine Doku.
>> SALLY: Also, was ich bei der anderen Bolo Tsunami hatte,
war natürlich, dass Erdbeerzeit war,
und ich konnte so Erdbeeren an den Rand schneiden.
Das sieht auch immer schön aus.
Oder Süßigkeiten könnt ihr nehmen.
Aber ich glaube, so eine Schicht Spekulatius,
das ist jetzt auch gut.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ich muss auch sagen...
>> SALLY: La, la, la, laa!
Ich versuche einfach, den Murat zu übertönen.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt habe ich das Video gecrasht.
Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Das hast du schon die ganze Zeit.
Aber ich habe dich mit schönem Weihnachtsgesang übertönt.
>> MURAT: Ja. Darf ich dir meinen Kumpel zeigen?
Güni, kannst du mal kurz kommen?
>> SALLY: Güni ist mein Freund und nicht deiner.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Genau.
Das ist Güni.
>> SALLY: Güni, sag ihm, dass du wegen mir da bist.
>> MURAT: Wenn ihr Güni noch nicht kanntet,
jeder kennt Güni.
[Applaus]
Er wird gesucht von Interpol
und von der CIA.
>> GÜNTER: Sally, sag was.
>> MURAT: Interpol kennt dich auch, gell?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Mach ihm aua.
>> MURAT: Nein!
>> GÜNTER: Au ja! Au ja!
>> MURAT: Nein. Hör auf jetzt!
>> GÜNTER: Nein!
>> MURAT: Hör auf jetzt!
So, der Güni.
Bitte keine Witze gegenüber mir.
>> GÜNTER: Nein.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und wenn du ruhig bist
und wenn wir beide nichts reden,
dann merkt keiner, wie dumm wir eigentlich sind, gell?
>> GÜNTER: Du.
>> MURAT: Du.
Ich? Ich und du.
>> GÜNTER: Du.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Können wir dir helfen eigentlich?
>> SALLY: Ah, nee.
>> MURAT: Nicht?
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: Weil es was Feines ist wahrscheinlich, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Weiß du was? Wir kommen wieder,
wenn es um einen Braten geht
oder um Fleisch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> GÜNTER: Oder zum Probieren.
>> MURAT: Zum Probieren kommen wir wieder, okay?
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also ganz liebe Grüße.
Der Güni und ich gehen jetzt wieder in den Garten
und auf die Baustelle. Habe ich recht?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder einkaufen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also viel Spaß!
>> SALLY: Danke!
>> GÜNTER: Komm.
>> MURAT: Ja. Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
Ich muss noch mal Tortencreme machen.
>> MURAT: Der Güni ist da sehr gut.
Der Güni ist da...
>> INTERVIEWER: Was ist das Wichtigste? Dass man
einfach auf alles reagieren kann immer sofort spontan?
>> MURAT: Das ist saumäßig wichtig.
>> GÜNTER: Oder es klappt auch nicht so, wie wir das wollen.
>> SALLY: Ich stelle das jetzt kurz kühl,
mache noch mal eine Creme
und backe noch mal einen Biskuit für obendrauf.
Denn
ich glaube, sonst klappt das mit dem Bolo Tsunami nicht.
Aber jetzt backe ich noch mal
den gleichen Biskuit, den ich vorhin hatte,
aber als Platte und steche es dann aus.
Dann habe ich eine dünne Platte.
Guckt einmal. Jetzt kann ich euch sogar beides zeigen.
So wollte ich es ja ursprünglich machen.
Und ich habe ja jetzt hier noch mal den Ring,
in der gleichen Größe einen Ausstecher
und kann jetzt hier
– ta-da-da-daa! –
das drauflegen.
Denn ich denke, so ein Biskuitabschluss ist schon ganz gut.
>> ELA: Mama, darf ich mitmachen bei dem Kuchen?
>> SALLY: Ja, da kannst du mitmachen.
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich auch mitmachen?
>> SALLY: Ja, du kannst auch mitmachen.
Aber der muss jetzt sowieso erst mal in den Kühlschrank.
>> ELA: Naschen!
>> SALLY: Ach so!
>> SAMIRA: Sind das so kleine Törtchen?
>> SALLY: Ja! Wir machen Mini-Bolo-Tsunami!
>> ELA: Ich will mitmachen.
>> SAMIRA: Auch mit dieser Creme?
Also, wo es dann so runterfließt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Cool!
>> SALLY: Cool, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> SAMIRA: Muss ich Spaghetti mit Tomatensoße essen?
>> SALLY: Mh.
Du kannst auch Käsespätzle essen.
>> SAMIRA: Juhu!
[Signalton Backofen]
>> SALLY: So. Und dann kommen nämlich
– Essen ist warm.
Dann kommt nämlich das Ganze jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Der Bolo Tsunami kühlt ja auch noch.
Und den lege ich gleich obendrauf.
Meistens ist ja echt das Video immer so recht ruhig,
aber manchmal ist es halt auch einfach so, wie es ist.
Und mein Alltag ist immer
recht spontan und sehr
spontan.
>> ELA: Hey!
>> SALLY: Hey.
Was machst du denn da?
>> ELA: Dir helfen.
>> SALLY: Oh, danke!
Damit können wir gleich ein anderes Törtchen füllen.
Ich habe nämlich noch Creme übrig.
Also das kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Sobald der Bolo Tsunami, also die Creme auch abgekühlt ist,
gieße ich sie noch drauf.
Und dann gucken wir mal und dekorieren fertig.
Und bei uns gibt es jetzt Mittagessen!
>> SAMIRA: Juhu!
>> ELA: Was ist ein Bolo Tsunami?
>> SALLY: Das soll dir mal die Samira erklären.
>> SAMIRA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mittagessen!
[Musik]
So.
Also jetzt machen wir kurz eine Fließprobe.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt gucken, ob die Glasur
dick genug ist, dass sie über den Kuchen fließt,
aber dünn genug, dass sie eben alles überdeckt.
Also wir probieren es aus.
Ich habe jetzt einfach noch mal so einen Ring.
>> JOSH: Ist es nicht andersrum?
>> SALLY: Dick genug ist, dass...
>> JOSH: Nee, dünn genug, dass sie fließt.
>> SALLY: Dünn genug, dass sie fließt,
und dick genug,
>> JOSH: Dass sie überdeckt.
>> SALLY: dass sie überdeckt. Danke.
Okay.
Wir probieren es einfach mal so.
>> ELA: Ja, komm schnell.
Schnell.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, wenn ich so
– ich glaube, 1,5 cm, 2 cm
dürfte reichen.
>> SAMIRA: Der ultimative Test.
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm, wir testen es kurz.
Und losziehen.
Uh!
Das wird gut!
Okay. Jetzt hole ich die Bolo Tsunami Cakes
und packe die Glasur drauf.
Und dann wird gegessen.
>> ELA: Darf ich mal?
>> SAMIRA: Warte mal. Stopp! Stopp! Stopp!
>> SALLY: Ja, probier erst mal. Probier es.
>> SAMIRA: Schmeckt nach Kondensmilch.
>> SALLY: Ja? Habe ich auch drin.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, ich weiß.
>> SALLY: Ach so.
>> ELA: Ich will auch mal probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Steht doch da.
>> SALLY: Ach so.
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, deine Tochter will noch was haben.
>> SALLY: Und ich so: "Wow, voll der Feinschmecker!"
>> ELA: Ich will auch probieren.
>> SALLY: Probier auch.
>> JOSH: Oh, Ela, bist du ein bisschen verschmiert?
>> SAMIRA: Weil Kondensmilch...
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Weil das eher so etwas dickflüssiger ist
>> SALLY: Schmeckt es, Ela?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: und so wie Kondensmilch schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Richtig gut!
>> SALLY: Also jetzt packt ihr hier die Glasur drauf.
Und ich werde dann noch essbare Sterne draufstreuen
und das Ganze so ein bisschen hübsch einpacken.
Und dann habt ihr im Prinzip euer Dessert vorbereitet.
Okay, ich muss sagen,
es ist schon jetzt ein Monsterdessert geworden.
>> ELA: Mum, auf meinem Rücken...
>> SALLY: Esst am Abend am besten nicht so viel.
Lasst Platz fürs Dessert.
Oder teilt es euch halt so zu zweit oder zu viert.
Ist ja auch okay.
Aber, guck mal, wie abgemessen.
>> ELA: Wie mein Schnee.
>> SALLY: Zumindest die Glasur war jetzt perfekt.
Ja.
Oh, ich nehme diese Silver Stars,
die zum Essen, die dünnen.
Und dann fließen die wie so ein Sternregen drüber
– hoffe ich.
>> JOSH: Was meinst du?
Kommt es in die Kategorie Schmecksperimente oder...
>> SALLY: Ach! Im Moment denke ich,
es kommt schon in die Kategorie Schöne Torten.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> ELA: Das ist Peppa Wutz.
>> JOSH: Nee, auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und jetzt machen wir gleich eine schöne Schleife drum,
richten es an.
Und wie gesagt, so könnt ihr es vorbereiten
und auch abdecken, am Tag vorher auch vorbereiten
und beim Weihnachtsessen
oder beim Geburtstag oder am Silvesterabend
dann einfach schön auspacken.
Und ich glaube, ich kann jetzt auch schon mal
den Ring gleich wegnehmen.
Aber ich hole erst die Schleife.
Oh! Du machst so eine süße Peppa Wutz!
>> ELA: Ja, die können wir aus Fondant machen.
>> SALLY: Ja, megacool, Ela!
>> ELA: Aber meine Ideen sind schon toll.
>> SALLY: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Das ist das größte Dessert,
das ich jemals bekommen habe.
>> SALLY: Ach Sarah!
Das schaffst du schon.
>> SARAH: Das ist eine Ehre.
Aber ich werde es nicht schaffen.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir es uns teilen?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir erst mal gucken,
ob es schön drüberläuft?
>> SARAH: Das auf jeden Fall.
Das ist gerade Premiere.
Ich war beim ersten Bolo Tsunami nicht da.
>> SALLY: Ah, stimmt!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sie war beim ersten nicht da.
>> SARAH: Ich habe es noch nie gesehen.
>> SALLY: Hast du ein Problem mit deinem Licht?
>> SARAH: Mit meinem Licht?
Ja, das springt die ganze Zeit nach oben.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Willst du zuerst oder ich?
>> SARAH: Du.
>> SALLY: Nein, du.
>> SARAH: Nein, du bist schöner.
>> SALLY: Nee, du.
Okay, wir nehmen erst deinen.
Okay, komm.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Oder sollen wir Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck?
>> SALLY: Aber nur einmal.
>> SARAH: Weißt du, wie wir das schon mal gemacht haben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Da drüben mit dem Metados.
>> SALLY: Mach mal.
>> SARAH: Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck.
Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck.
Ha, ha!
Wer ist jetzt?
>> SALLY: Du.
>> SARAH: Ah, ich darf.
Gut.
Ich ziehe es einfach hoch?
>> SALLY: Hm. Und gerade hoch. Gerade hoch.
>> SARAH: Ich kann nichts kaputt machen?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Einfach hoch. Hoch, hoch, hoch!
>> SARAH: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Wuhu!
>> SALLY & SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Wie das so schön darüberläuft!
>> SARAH: So.
Oh, ist das schön!
>> SALLY: Okay, ich nehme meins auch hoch.
Willst du meins auch noch?
>> JOSH: Au ja!
>> SARAH: Zieh! Zieh! Zieh!
>> JOSH: Zieh!
>> SARAH: Ah!
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ist das schön!
Oh, sieht das toll aus!
>> SARAH: Es ist echt toll.
Die Sternchen, die so runterfließen.
>> SALLY: Gell? Das ist wie so ein Sternhimmel.
>> SARAH: Ja!
Ganz viele Sternschnuppen.
Wünscht euch etwas!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Wünsch dir schnell was!
>> SALLY: Komm, wir probieren, ja?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss schon sagen,
so eine Portion ist schon riesig.
Ich würde sogar fast sagen,
wie so eine Sterne-
>> SARAH: Das ist größer als mein Kopf.
>> SALLY: Ja, wie so ein Sternedessert
kam man das ja auch zu viert teilen,
dass jeder so eine Miniportion hat.
>> SARAH: Zu viert?
>> SALLY: Sollen wir es aufschneiden?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Ah!
>> SALLY: Oh, das sieht so smooth aus!
>> SARAH: Smooth criminal!
Degga-degga-degga-demm-demm,
degga-demm-demm,
degga-demm-demm-demm!
>> SALLY: Guck mal!
>> SARAH: Oh, wie es da runterläuft!
>> SALLY: Ja. Und dann, guck mal, so
zack.
>> JOSH: Hand weg! Hand weg!
>> SARAH: Entschuldige.
Oh, das ist Weihnachten!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Das ist richtig Weihnachten.
Die Tonkabohne auch.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Das passt perfekt zu Spekulatius.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Ich glaube, ich esse zu Hause Spekulatius
und mache Tonkapaste drauf.
>> SALLY: So ein perfektes Dessert, gell?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich finde es echt schön so für Weihnachten,
muss ich sagen.
Ich meine, ihr könnt ja
– ihr müsst ja kein Spekulatiusgewürz benutzen
und Spekulatiuskekse,
aber passt schon gut, muss ich sagen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also echt gut.
Und ich finde es auch nicht zu süß. Du?
>> SARAH: Überhaupt nicht eigentlich.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SARAH: Mhm.
Eher so fruchtig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Hm.
>> SARAH: Ist das weiße Schokolade?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich habe statt dunkler Schokolade weiße Schokolade rein.
Also probiert das Rezept gerne mal aus.
In meiner App findet ihr noch mal alle Mengenangaben
und natürlich auch auf sallys-blog.de.
Und übrigens gibt es von uns ja seit Längerem einen Podcast.
Den könnt ihr euch jeden Donnerstag anhören.
Da kommt immer eine neue Folge.
Und ich muss auch echt sagen, die sind ziemlich unterhaltsam.
Ja, da erfährt man so ein bisschen,
was bei uns im Leben alles passiert backstage.
Also frohe Weihnachten.
Okay, es ist noch nicht Weihnachten, aber bald.
>> SARAH: In welche Kamera sage ich es jetzt?
Frohe Weihnachten!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
[Musik]